[Musique]
présidur
président
bien je vous
[Applaudissements]
remerci
bien mesdames messieurs je voudrais tout
d'abord saluer et
remercier les
journalistes les photographes les
techniciens qui ont bien voulu répondre
à mon
invitation et je leur exprime très
sincèrement ma
gratitude le 3 février
dernier j'ai annoncé que je serai
candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
aujourd'hui à l'issue d'un long silence
au cours duquel j'ai beaucoup travaillé
j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi je voudrais vous indiquer
quelles sont les
raisons qui m'ont conduit à prendre
cette
décision dans quel esprit j'entends
conduire cette
campagne et quels sont les
objectifs que je veux proposer aux
françaises et aux
Français pour
qu'ensemble nous puissions
surmonter les difficultés que traverse
notre
pays en août
1976 j'ai observé que les propositions
que je faisais n'étaient pas pr en
considération et que je n'avais donc pas
les
moyens de conduire la politique qui me
semblait nécessaire pour la
France j'en ai tiré les
conclusions et j'ai démissionné de mes
fonctions de Premier
ministre j'ai continué alors à faire des
propositions notamment dans le domaine
de la politique économique et de la
politique
sociale sans il est
vrai être
entendu et nous sommes
arrivés aux élections législatives de
1978 j'ai participé alors activement à
la
campagne j'ai pris une part
essentielle à la victoire de la
majorité
et j'ai sincèrement pensé alors qu'un
nouveau départ serait pris que quelque
chose
changerait et comme beaucoup de
Françaises et de
français j'ai été
déçu que les choses continuent comme
s'il ne s'était rien passé comme s'il ne
s'était rien dit pendant ce grand
débat j'ai indiqué
alors
qu'à peu de temps de l'élection
présidentielle je n'avais pas
l'intention d'ajouter une crise
politique à la crise économique qui
touchait notre
pays et que les choses devraient être
tranchées par l'ensemble des Français à
l'occasion du grand débat qui
s'ouvrirait en préalable à l'élection
présidentielle et voilà
pourquoi il était dans la logique même
de mon comportement politique depuis 5
ans que je prenne la décision d'être
candidat
aujourd'hui mais il y avait à vrai dire
une deuxième
raison et qui tenait au
fait que si je n'avais pas pris cette
décision il y a de fortes
chances pour que les Français se soit
trouvé dans l'obligation de choisir en
1981 exactement comme ils avaient dû le
faire en
1974 c'est-à-dire entre monsieur Valérie
giscardestin dont le bilan à l'issue de
son
ne conduisait pas spontanément et de gêé
de cœur une majorité d'entre nous a
souhaité lui donner un nouveau bail de 7
ans et Monsieur François
mitteran qui n'est pas aujourd'hui
différent de ce qu'il était en
1974 puisqu'il se présente à nos
suffrages avec le même
programme et avec les mêmes
alliances car même s'il n'est plus le
candidat unique de la
gauche il ne peut pas être élu sans
recueillir au deè tour la totalité des
suffrages
communistes étrange destin que celui
d'un grand pays se trouvant en quelque
sorte dans
l'obligation de retarder de C temps la
pendule de
l'histoire
comme si rien ne s'était passé depuis
1974 comme s'il n'y avait pas des
tensions des risques de guerre dans le
monde qui n'existait pas alors comme si
la
France cétait pas affaiblie à
l'intérieur miné par l'inflation et par
le
chômage comme s'il n'y avait pas 8
millions d'électrices et
d'électeurs qui seront présents aux
urnes cette année et qui ne l'était pas
en
1974 mais qui exprime la jeunesse de la
France avec ces problèmes
nouveaux quant à
moi j'ai
estimé qu'il fallait proposer aux
Français une nouvelle
voie et c'est pour la
tracer que je suis aujourd'hui
candidat c'est pour leur
montrer que l'on peut réaliser le
changement nécessaire
aujourd'hui mais que celui-ci peut
s'effectuer sans risque et dans le
respect des valeurs et des principes qui
depuis 22 ans ont été ceux de la 5e
République voilà pour les raisons un mot
maintenant sur
l'esprit je diraiis tout de suite que
j'entends conduire cette
campagne en excluant
totalement toute espèce de
polémique j'estime en
effet que la situation de la France est
assez grave
aujourd'hui pour qu'un homme politique
responsable ne se laisse pas
aller à des querelles
stériles personnelles ou
partisanes le débat
traditionnel
politicien n'est pas mon affaire
elle n'est pas l'affaire des Français
non plus et je vous dis tout de suite
que je ne me laisserai en aucun cas
entraîner sur ce
terrain
enfin les
objectifs je n'ai bien sûr pas
aujourd'hui la
prétention
d'évoquer tous les problèmes mais je
voudrais simplement souligner
quelques
idées à mes yeux
essentiell pour la grandeur de la France
et pour le bonheur des français tant il
est vrai qu'il n'y a pas de France forte
sans des Français fiers et heureux
d'appartenir à la
France le premier
objectif c'est de
redonner place et son autorité à la
France dans le
monde
retrouver la place que le général de
Gaulle et George Pompidou avaient donné
à notre pays et qui est aujourd'hui
disons-le affaibli et contesté ceci
tenant à une démarche trop
hésitante ceci tenant à une insuffisante
fermeté à l'égard des prétenions des uns
et des autres et notamment des
Soviétiques ce C tenante à une
insuffisance de générosité ou
d'imagination face au problème du
développement des pays pauvres
ou des exigences des droits de l'homme
bafoué dans tant et tant de
pays la
France doit retrouver
une voix ferme et claire à la fois pour
défendre sans compromis les intérêts qui
sont les siens et pour porter le message
de paix et d'amitié qui a toujours été
le
sien sans oublier bien sûr et dans le
même esprit les exigences de sa défense
et notamment le nécessaire
renforcement de ces moyens de dissuasion
nucléaire
et de ses moyens
d'intervention le deuxème objectif
concerne ce qu'exige la démocratie
aujourd'hui les temps ne sont pas si
lointains où la faiblesse des
démocraties a ouvert la porte aux
dictatures il faut se rendre compte
aujourd'hui que la démocratie doit
s'exercer avec suffisamment
d'autorité si l'on veut préserver
la sécurité et les libertés de nos
concitoyens il faut lorsque la loi et
voter se donner à la fois la volonté et
les moyens de l'appliquer sans
faiblesse le trè objectif concerne notre
situation
économique curieuse situation en effet
que celle d'un pays où se côtoie sans
s'entendre une
majorité qui brandit en permanence les
slogans de liberté d'initiative de
responsabilité mais qui laisse jour
après jour s'insinuer
sournoisement une sorte de collectivisme
rampant en développant l'emprise de plus
en plus grande de l'État et de
l'administration sur la vie des
individus comme sur l'activité des
entreprises et une
opposition qui voit petit à petit se
réaliser son
programme sans y être pour rien et bien
il faut interrompre ce
processus et rendre la liberté à notre
économie et notamment à nos
entreprises si nous voulons
notamment donner
ce qui est essentiel et n'a pas été
suffisamment compris
jusqu'ici la priorité à la lutte contre
le chômage seule condition de pouvoir
réduire
efficacement l'inflation qui ronge notre
monnaie il y a enfin notre politique
sociale qui doit se départir aujourd'hui
de ces deux
tentations que sont la génér
l'assistance ou
encore la
démagogie qui conduit notamment pendant
les périodes
électorales à faire trop de promesses
qui ne seront pas
tenu il faut
savoir que la rigueur exige aujourd'hui
de déterminer avec soin les priorités
d'une politique
sociale ces priorités selon moi concern
la politique
familiale la politique du logement et la
politique de
participation je ne voudrais pas
allonger ce propos
liminaire car j'aurai l'occasion de
répondre à vos questions et d'exposer
plus complètement quelles sont mes idées
et aussi l'ensemble des solution que je
veux apporter au problèmes auquels nous
sommes confrontés je le ferai à
l'occasion des voyages en province car
j'entends bien sûr rester au contact des
Françaises et des Français et je
rencontrerai probablement un certain
nombre d'entre vous pendant ces voyages
où je développerai tel ou tel thème
particulier je le ferai aussi à
l'occasion de conférences de presse
régulière tous les 15 jours environ au
cours
desquelles je vous ferai part de mes
réactions aux différentes situations
éc ou internation qui pouront se
présenter pendant cette
période mais pour aujourd'hui je me
limiterai à ce court
propos et en vous remerciant à la fois
de votre présence et de votre
patience nous allons si vous voulez bien
maintenant passer au débat proprement
parler je donnerai volontiers la parole
à ceux qui la souhaitent en précisant
peut-être la règle du jeu c'est-à-dire
que nous pourrions évoquer pendant une
demiheure ou TR qu d'heure les problèmes
de politique intérieure je veux dire
essentiellement les problèmes
économiques et
sociaux avant d'évoquer ensuite les
problèmes de politique étrangère si
cette règle du jeu vous convient et bien
nous pourrons
commencer
je donne la parole à Monsieur Passeron
qui vient de la demander monsieur le
Président depuis 4 ans vous critiquez
sans cesse l'action économique du
gouvernement vous avez même annoncé
récemment que si elle se poursuivait
elle mènerait à la Révolution vous
demandez également qu'une politique
nouvelle soit faite mais tout ce que
vous avez proposé depuis lors n'a jamais
été retenu par ce gouvernement pour
lequel né moins vous votez est-ce que ce
manque d'audience et de crédibilité de
vos propositions ne vient pas de leur
imprécision ou de leur insuffisance en
quelque sorte est-ce que vous avez un
remède à la crise économique
actuelle je voudrais faire une première
observation j'aiévoqué tout à
l'heure l'incohérence
entre le
discours qui se
veut
libéral et l'action
quotidienne qui est tout à fait
différente je voudrais d'abord
indiquer qu'il faut choisir le type
d'économie dans lequel nous voulons
vivre en
1974 l'ensemble des
prélèvement fiscaux et
parafiscaux représent
un peu plus de 36
% du produit intérieur brut
total en
81 l'ensemble de ces
prélèvements représente 42
% de ce produit intérieur brut total
entretemps Monsieur G alors ministre des
Finances avait indiqué et j'étais
totalement de son
avis que lorsqueun société franchit le
seuil de 40 % de prélèvement elle change
de type et de structure économique et
qu'elle entre dans le
socialisme c'est
vrai et bien je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce pourcentage de
prélèvement avec ce que cela
implique comme développement de l'action
et des contraintes que l'État et
l'administration fait peser sur
l'ensemble de
l'économie est tout à fait excessif et
qu'il faut inverser aujourd'hui la
tendance et ma première observation sera
pour dire qu'il me paraît
urgent de revenir dans un premier temps
à un taux de prélèvement qui n'excède
pas 40 %
pour revenir dans les délais les plus
brefs possibles à un taux raisonnable de
prélèvement c'est-à-dire de l'ordre de
%. car si nous continuons au rythme que
nous avons soutenu pendant ce
SEPA encore une période de 7 ans et les
Français travailleront un jour sur deux
pour payer leurs impôts et leurs
cotisation
sociales à ce moment-là
il est tout à fait inutile de se poser
la question de savoir s'il convient ou
non de voter pour le programme
socialiste ça se fera
inéluctablement revenir à 40% cela veut
dire quoi cela veut dire faire de
l'ordre de 60 milliard
d'économie chiffre
considéra notre produit intérieur vous
le savez éant aux environs de 3100
milliards de francs
et bien je propose
qu'on réalise cet effort en 2 ans et en
commençant par une première étape d'une
trentaine de milliards dès cette
année et je chercherai pour ma part cet
effort en diminuant la pression fiscale
et en appliquant l'essentiel de cette
diminution à l'impôt sur le revenu je
sais bien que l'on me dira qu'en France
l'impôt sur le revenu est faible par
rapport à ce qui existe dans la plupart
des grands États industriels qui nous
entourent c'est
faux car si l'on prend en considération
l'impôt sur le revenu et les cotisations
sociales nous sommes très exactement
dans la
moyenne je proposerai donc d'une part
que soit totalement exonéré d'impôt sur
le
revenu tous les foyers fiscaux au nombre
de quelques 5 millions et
demi qui ont un revenu inférieur à 3300
francs par
mois et que réaffirmant le principe de
l'indexation nécessaire et sans
exception du barê de l'impôt sur le
revenu dans toutes ces tranches pour
compenser ce qui n'a pas été fait depuis
quelques temps à ce sujet je proposerai
pour l'année
81 un abattement
de l'ordre de 5 % sur l'impôt sur le
revenu de l'ensemble des autres des
autres
contribuables je propose
également la suppression de la taxation
sur les plus-values c'est-à-dire de la
loi de
1976 de même que la remise en cause des
droits de
succession sur la transmission des
petites et des moyennes
entreprises
enfin une
accentuation des mesures récemment
prises et qui sont excellentes
relatives à la déduction du bénéfice
imposable pour les
investissements j'attends de cette
réduction de la pression fiscale un
redémarrage de
l'offre et par voie de
conséquence une diminution de la
pression sur la monnaie et de
l'inflation j'attends aussi de cette
perspective la reprise de l'économie
mais ce n'est pas suffisant je vous ai
dit tout à
l'heure qu'il était essentiel de
réaliser que la cause de l'inflation
aujourd'hui dans notre
pays n'est
pas l'offre ou la
demande comme le croient les économistes
faisante référence à des doctrines
aujourd'hui
dépassées mais bien le ch
on dit pas assz
que le chômage coûte à la collectivité
actuellement quelques C milliards de
francs par an c'estdire 100 milliards de
francs qui sont dépensés pour indemniser
et c'est
légitime les
chômeurs sans qu'il y ait la moindre
contrepartie en matière de production de
bien ou de
service il n'y a pas d'effet plus
inflationniste
et il faut par conséquent se rendre
compte que en même temps que le chômage
l'inflation s'accroit en 1976 j'ai dit
et j'ai écrit que l'orientation prise
par notre politique économique
conduirait chaque année à une
augmentation de 200000 chômeurs et par
voie de conséquence à une augmentation
de 1 point à 1 point et demi de notre
hausse des
prix lorsque j'ai quitté le gouvernement
l'inflation était de 9,5 % elle est
aujourd'hui de près de
14% il y a 16000 chômeurs hélas je ne
m'étais pas
trompé il faut donner la priorité à la
création des emplois et par conséquent
demander où on peut trouver la
possibilité de le faire ce n'est pas
c'est vrai dans la grande
industrie si la France veut conserver
demain les structures industrielles d'un
grand État moderne et qui lui ont été
donné par le général de Gaulle et
surtout par George Pompidou
elle ne doit pas entraver sa grande
industrie par des contraintes fell celle
de l'emploi elle doit lui permettre au
contraire en permanence de se
moderniser d'affirmer sa productivité et
ses capacités de compétition dans le
monde ce n'est pas hlas l'agriculture
qui créera ses
emplois les services ils participeront
sans aucun doute mais pas au niveau
suffisant pour faire face aux quelques 6
à 700000 demandeurs d'emploi nouveaux
qui arrivent tous les ans sur le marché
du
travail et qui
sont beaucoup plus nombreux compte tenu
de la
démographie que les quelques 400000
travailleurs qui prennent chaque année
leur retraite et pour diminuer en même
temps le nombre des demandeurs d'emplois
existants c'est donc une autre politique
qu'il il faut chercher cette politique
il faut
l'appliquer à l'ensemble de ces 2
millions de petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sur l'ensemble du
territoire national présente un
potentiel d'initiative de responsabilité
de productivité considérable mais qui
aujourd'hui sont systématiquement
paralysés par cette action excessive
pesante inadaptée qui est celle d'une
administration conduite par une
technocratie qui devient chaque jour
plus puissante et qui prend le pouvoir
réel au détriment du politique qui seul
devrait
l'exercer il faut libérer notre économie
je le disais tout à l'heure et notamment
libérer ces petites et moyennes
entreprises des contraintes qui pèsent
sur
elles il faut pour se
faire aménager notre système fiscal et
d'abord supprimer la taxe
professionnelle 35 milliards de
francs alors que cet impôt chacun le
sait pénalise de façon absurde à la fois
l'investissement l'emploi l'exportation
et la
concurrence en raison de ces
considérables variations d'une commune à
l'autre il faut bien entendu affecter
aux communes de France la contrepartie
de cette perte et donc leur donner au
sein de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement une dotation
représentative de la taxe
professionnelle indexée sur la TVA pour
qu'elle n'y perde rien c'est vrai et il
faut donc que l'État récupère les sommes
correspondantes ce qui doit être fait
par un autre impôt mais qui soit moderne
35 milliards cela représente environ
1% d'augmentation de la TVA c'estàdire
en clair une augmentation de de points
de chacun des taux de la TVA ce qui est
parfaitement
supportable et ce qui n'aura pas sur les
prix d'incidence supérieure à celle que
l'on enregistre par la taxe
professionnelle qui est naturellement
elle
aussi transporté dans les prix répercuté
dans les prix
il y a les contraintes d'ordre
juridique nous ne pouvons plus appliquer
aujourd'hui comme elles avaient été
élaboré en période de plein emploi les
règles sur les licenciements qui
paralyse toute capacité de recrutement
il faut de façon contractuelle les
modifier et les adapter nous devons
mettre au point un véritable statut de
la soustraitance nous devons trouver des
solution à ces problèmes irritants qui
sont ceux des seuils pour les petites et
moyennes
entreprises il y a les contraintes
d'ordre
financier il faut créer un outil moderne
de crédit pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises et qui probablement doit
être un outil d'ordre mutualiste et
décentralisé comme le Crédit Agricole
mais adapté aux besoins des petites et
moyennes entreprises il y a les
contraintes d'ordre bureaucratique
qui incontestablement sont de plus en
plus insupportables et paralysantes pour
ces 2 millions
d'entreprises et sur lesquelles il faut
revenir de façon à les libérer elles
n'ont pas les moyens de les
assumer vous savez je disais 2 millions
en forme de boutade je vous diraiis que
si chacune des petites et moyennes
entreprises en France
créer un emploi il n'y aurait plus de
problème d'emploi et vraisemblablement
plus de problèm d'inflation
naturellement cela exige parallèlement
et je ne le développerai pas ici en tous
les cas aujourd'hui une réforme profonde
de notre système d'éducation et de
formation naturellement mais enfin c'est
bien là l'orientation qu'il faut donner
voilà Monsieur Passeron ce que je
souhaitais
indiquer pour dire qu'il y a une
autreque de l'économie qui est possible
et qu'il est urgente aujourd'hui de
l'appliquer monsieur
fr un tout petit peu plus fort s'il vous
plaîtur journal le matin vous faites de
la lutte contre le chômage ce que j'ai
compris pierre la pierre angulaire de
votre système pouvez-vous plus
précisément nous expliquer comment vousz
allit stopper un mouvement qui qui a été
engagé bien avant septembre
1976 j'ai
essayé de vous indiquer quelles étaient
les solutions que je préconisais je ne
voudrais pas
me me
répéter je crois que ce mouvement qui
effectivement a été engagé avant
1976 mais qui depuis a pris une ampleur
considérable et insupportable pour des
raisons
tant humaines et sociales que pour des
raisons économiques doit son
développement à une erreur de jugement
quant à la politique économique qui doit
être
poursuivie je ne répéterai pas ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure mais je crois
que la solution au problème de l'emploi
doit être recherchée dans la libération
de notre économie des contraintes qui
pèsent de façon excessive sur
elle et que la diminution de ce chômage
se traduira
inévitablement par une diminution des
tensions sur la monnaie c'est-à-dire par
une diminution de l'inflation et que
nous retrouverons peu à peu les
équilibres que nous avons perdu je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes enfermés dans
les séquelles mal adapté des théories
kénésiennes qui avait tout prévu sauf
que l'on pouvait avoir en même temps
dans un pays industriel la stagnation et
l'inflation Berlin Allemagne férale
monsieur Chirac le gouvernement explique
le taux de chômage en partie par la
situation démographique acceptez-vous ce
raisonnement est-ce que cela veut dire
qu'il faut dire au français renoncer aux
enfants au nouveau né parce que chaque
nouveau est un
chômeur perspective
merci non monsieur je crois que il n'y a
pas de rapport et je pense que le
chômage ne peut se développer ne peut
que se développer avec la baisse de la
démographie je crois que
l'une des sources de consommation et de
demandes les plus importantes résident
précisément dans les enfants et dans une
démographie forte et par conséquent je
récuse toute thèse tendant à dire que
pour lutter contre le chômage il faut
s'arrêter de faire des
enfants Monsieur K monsieur je crois
qu'on peut dire sans aucune contestation
possible que votre décision de miser en
74 sur le camp de Monsieur juscestin et
de donner ainsi le premier président de
la République nuliste à la France de la
5e
République est-ce que cette décision que
vous avez prise donc il y a 7 ans vous
la regrettez aujourd'hui
rtrpement je ne regrette rien cher
Monsieur
car à
l'époque le choix était entre l'aventure
de l'incertain et la certitude de
l'aventure et bien j'ai
choisi monsieur revenir économi quel
lien faites-vous entre l'ardente
obligation du plan et l'économie
libérale que vous avez comme
objectif je crois
que
le plan est effectivement une ardente
obligation et qu'il n'y a pas surtout de
contradiction
entre la planification et la libération
de l'économie il est tout à fait évident
et c'est l'une des réserves que j'ai
formulé régulièrement depuis un certain
temps sur l'action
gouvernementale que nous devons redonner
à la planification telle que je
l'entends c'est-à-dire une planification
qui n'est pas bureaucratique et
contraignante
mais qui définit des choix et détermine
les cheminements pour atteindre des
objectifs la place qui doit être la
sienne l'économie française au lendemain
de la dernière guerre mondiale s'est
relevée grâce à l'action engagée dans le
prer le 2è et le 3è plan au lendemain de
1958 les succès de notre économie sont d
notamment au fait que le plan on avait
fixé très exactement le cadre et les
moyens et je souhaite cela va de soi que
l'on redonne à la planification la
vocation qui est la sienne et qu'elle
redevienne effectivement une ardente
obligation je veux dire par là que le
plan est à mes yeux une procédure
concerté tendant à établir des objectifs
donc des priorités et à mettre en place
les moyens qui doivent être qui doivent
exister pour atteindre ces objectifs il
faute à l'évidence même une politique
énergétique une politique industrielle
un certain nombre une politique agricole
et ceci ne peut être fait de façon
cohérente que dans un cadre qui soit
tracé et qui ne peut être que le plan et
dans mes proposition il y a
naturellement la restauration du plan
qui aujourd'hui n'existe
plus monsieur est-ce que vous voyez dans
même ligne politique c'està-dire
conservatrice que Madame tcher et
Monsieur
Rean vous me demandez si je suis dans la
même ligne politique
oui écoutez après tout c'est une ligne
qui n'est pas si mauvaise puisque les
deux personnalités que vous me citez ont
gagné les
élections alors je me dis qu'après tout
cette
effectivement mais je vais vous dire
chère
madame je crois que chaque pays a ses
caractéristiques ses problèmes et que
l'on ne peut pas appliquer à l'un ce qui
est valable pour
l'autre et croyez bien que si je me suis
réjoui de l'élection du président des
États-Unis non pas sur le plan personnel
parce que je ne le connais pas mais dans
la mesure où il était pour moi le
symbole d'un sursaut de la grande nation
américaine contre
l'affaiblissement je ne pense pas que
l'on
puisse extrapoler en France ce qui se
passe aux
États-Unis néanmoins je trouve
qu'actuellement les propositions
telleles qu'on peut les connaître du
président américain sont conformes à ce
qu'exige à la fois la grandeur des
États-Unis et les problèmes intérieurs
qui sont les mêmes c'est vrai que ceux
que connaît la France aux
États-Unis monsieur Chirac Michel Culin
télévision autrichienne journal di ARB
il vous arrive parfois de parler en
termes positifs de la social-démocratie
alors euh hier monsieur Denot euh vous a
placé dans la majorité et a estimé
finalement que euh en définitive au
second tour vous devriez euh vous
désister en faveur du de Valérie
giscardestin est-ce que vous pensez que
d'autres majorités sont poss possible
jusqu'ù que pensez-vous de la
proposition de George SARD lorsqu'il a
parlé d'une union très large
incluant Gauliste socialiste et
communiste vous savez cher Monsieur dans
l'esprit de nos
institutions la
majorité pour une large part sort des
urnes à l'occasion de l'élection
présidentielle et bien nous verrons bien
au lendemain de ces élections ce qui se
passera
vous croez
pouir ch monsieur non vous n'avez pas
entendu mais je vais répéter monsieur
demande
si de la façon dont je présente les
choses je crois pouvoir gagner cette
élection cette fois-ci c'est bien ce que
vous
avez ch monsieur si je n'avais pas la
conviction de gagner vous ne me
trouveriez pas aujourd'hui devant vous
je n'ai aucune intention d'aller faire
un petit tour de porter un
témoignage j'ai trop de respect pour les
électrices et les électeurs et aussi
beaucoup de choses à faire pour ne pas
m'engager dans un combat politique avec
la ferme résolution de le
gagner j'avais fait la même réponse
à une question identique posé peut-être
avec plus de scepticisme par un de vos
confrères au début de ma campagne pour
les élections municipales à
Paris nouvel économist vous nous avez
indiqué votre intention de faire 30
milliard d'économie en une année mais si
j'ai bien compris vous n'avez pas
indiqué par quelle nouvelle recette vous
compenseriez ce trou alors est-ce que
vous avez l'intention de supprimer des
prestations sociales ou de couper dans
tel ou tel
budget je n'ai pas dit que je souhaitais
compenser par de nouvelles recettes
puisque mon intention est de revenir à
une
situation où le prélèvement général
opéré par l'État sur le revenu des
citoyens diminueent et par conséquent
ces 60 milliards qui en 2 ans
doivent impérativement disparaître du
prélèvement fiscal ne peuvent être
compensé que par une réduction de la
dépense réduction de la dépense qui peut
parfaitement être obtenue et dont je
propose qu'elle soit de 30 milliards
cette année et 30 milliards l'année
prochaine vous savez dans le budget 1980
le groupe politique auquel j'appartiens
avait proposé modestement de faire 2
milliards d'économie 2
et cela a provoqué des sursauts
d'indignation de la part d'un certain
nombre
d'expert et on ne les a pas fait
l'alignation en fait tenait à l'origine
de la proposition plus qu'à des raisons
techniques puisque aussi bien un an
après c'est-à-dire pour le budget de
1981 nous avons appris tout soudain que
le gouvernement avait décidé de faire 13
milliards d'économie ce qui l'a fait
d'ailleurs sans difficulté et ce dont je
l'ai
félicité et bien il faut aller
au-delà et que faut-il réduire
naturellement pas la dépense
d'équipement qui depuis 5 ans a été
systématiquement
sacrifié naturellement pas la dépense
militaire qui est aux limites de
l'insuffisance naturellement pas la
dépense de la dette puisqu'elle est
obligatoire il reste donc deux grands
chefs de
dépenses la dépense de fonctionnement et
la dépense
d'intervention 235 milliards pour l'une
189 milliards pour l'autre dans le
budget 1981 vous voyez qu'il y a tout de
même de la
marge je propose que l'on diminue l'une
et l'autre de ces
dépenses
et sans vouloir ici car le cadre ne s'y
prête pas à rentrer dans le détail je
vous dirai que c'est possible et que je
suis prêt à en développer les modalités
mais je retiendrai l'une d'entre elles
dans la
mesure où elle correspond non seulement
aux
exigences de la réduction de la dépense
mais aussi aux exigences de la
libération de notre économie et de nos
concitoyens c'est la dépense de
administration je ne dis pas qu'il y a
partout et uniformément trop de
fonctionnaire naturellement et je sais
bien des services où le nombre des
agents est très insuffisant je pense par
exemple à la sécurité au postes
télécommunication aux
hôpitaux mais je sais
aussi que nombreux sont les
services dont
l'inutilité manifeste qui ne relève pas
réellement de l'action souveraine de
l'État et qui en revanche paralysie
paralyse l'action des individus ou des
entreprises et ce que je
demande c'est que chaque ministère dans
chaque ministère chaque ministre pour
une
fois pour une fois ne se contente pas de
suivre ses techniciens et son
administration mais décide de supprimer
un certain nombre des actions
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas nécessaires et
qui sont conduites par son
administration et qu'il concentre ses
moyens sur les actions indispensables et
comme il faut toujours une incitation et
un encouragement je suggère que nous
prenions pendant quelques années la
règle de ne recruter chaque année qu'un
nombre de nouveaux fonctionnaires égal à
la moitié du nombre de ceux qui prennent
leur retraite la même
année c'est un effort c'est vrai
important mais c'est une discipline à
laquelle nous devons bien nous soumettre
ou alors il faut dire tout de suite que
nous avons l'intention de laisser
sournoisement se développer un système
étatique et socialiste qui est très
exactement le contraire de celui que
l'on prétend défendre par ailleurs dans
le discours politique
quotidien monsieur entre vous et
Monsieur Giscard desestin si les
candidats j'aimerais comprendre est-ce
qu'il s'agira de ce que l'on appelle
dans d'autres pays une élection primaire
c'est-à-dire qui se déroule à
l'intérieur du même camp ou est-ce qu'il
s'agira d'autre chose d'un jeu plus
compliqué à 3 par
exemple et bien vous verrez bien quel
est à cet égard mon comportement comme
nous observerons celui de Monsieur
giscardestin s'il est candidat et chacun
en tirera bien sûr les conclusions qu'il
estimera devoir en tirer je fais
confiance à votre sagacité pour le faire
monsieur j'ai deux questions à vous
poser une sérieuse et une apparemment
plus futile à vous de juger la première
vous êtes un spécialiste des marathons
européens alors actuellement si vous
deviez participer à un de ces marathons
ou donner des conseils à l'un de vos
ministres en supposant que vous deveniez
président de la République comment
défendriez-vous la sidérurgie française
face à la Commission européenne deuxème
question plus futile peut-être mais elle
est dans tous les journaux alors autant
vous la poser on parle beaucoup du de la
modification de votre image pour
renforcer votre crédibilité auprès des
électeurs alors qu'est-ce qui dans votre
image doit-être amélioré et comment
comptez-vous y
parvenir pour la deuxème question c'est
plutôt aux observateur et à vous-même de
porter un jugement et éventuellement de
me donner un conseil je suis toujours
très ouvert au conseils amicau que l'on
veut bien me donner sur le premier
point je vra dire tout d'abord
que au-delà de la question technique que
vous
posez il y a l'idée qu'on se fait de
l'Europe je
crois que nous sommes arrivés bien près
du
moment où nous devrons
réexaminer
l'ensemble des règles de la construction
européenne je suis bien sûr favorable à
un renforcement des solidarités
européennes mais chacun a bien
conscience également que nous sommes
dans une période de l'histoire où de
plus en plus s'affirment les
nationalités et qu'on ne peut pas aller
non plus à contrecourant de l'histoire
or le traité de Rome et c'est là sa
terrible
faiblesse ne choisit pas clairement
entre une
Europe qui se
ferait contre les états et en les vidant
de leur autorité et une Europe qui se
ferait par les état et en prenant appui
sur leur
autorité et après toute une période où
le nombre des participants et la bonne
volonté du départ ont permis des progrès
certains nous sommes arrivés à un moment
où dans tous les domaines cette
structure généreuse
est en train de se fissurer c'est vrai
pour la politique agricole commune
hélas c'est vrai pour l'ensemble des
autres
actions caractérisé par un absentéisme
redoutable notamment en matière de
politique industrielle ou de politique
énergétique ou de politique sociale ou
de bien
d'autres et c'est vrai notamment pour ce
qui concerne la
sidérurgie où l'on observe
une démarche là aussi très
hésitante d'une commission qui n'arrive
pas à réellement prendre en
considération la double exigence de
l'emploi dans notre Europe et de
l'impérieuse nécessité quel qu'en soit
éventuellement le
coup de
maintenir une production sidérurgique
importante
dans un grand pays industriel alors vous
me dites que
feriezvous je vais pas développer
longuement j'aurai l'occasion de le
faire notamment Loren et dans le Nord
mon idée sur la politique sidérurgique
mais je vous dir simplement qu toute
hypothèse et sa prendre des mesures
nationales dans le cas où je n'arriverai
pas à convaincre nos partenaires de
prendre des mesures
communautaires je protègerai notre
sidérurgie parce qu'il n'est pas de
France Forte possible il n'est pas de
structure industrielle moderne pour
notre pays si nous n'avons pas une
sidérurgie qui soit importante et qui
soit dynamique même si cela doit nous
coûter quelque chose Monsieur Chirac
avez-vous l'intention d'instituer un Imp
attendez monsieur les oblot peut pas
parler tout le monde ensemble n'est-ce
pas alors une question de transition
monsieur dès le lendemain de votre
déclaration de candidature l'association
de rapatrier le recours a estimé que
votre entrée en Liss était de nature je
cite à enrichir le débat sur les
problèmes relatifs à la réintégration
dans la communauté nationale des
Français rapatriés de toute confession
quelle appréciation
apportez-vous sur cette prise de
position c'est un sujet que j'ai
l'intention effectivement
d'aborder dans la mesure où il relève à
la
fois d'une conception de la
justice et de la nécessité de la
réconciliation
nationale la démarche dans ce domaine a
été il faut bien le dire un peu
chaotante et le contentieux a trop
duré le moment est venu c'est
vrai d'y mettre définitivement un terme
je crois qu'il faut le
faire
d'abord en prenant immédiatement un
certain nombre de mesures
techniques et qui permettent de rendre
plus
juste l'action telle qu'elle est
actuellement menée je pense aux
modalités concernant les titres
d'indemnisation et leur négociabilité je
pense au niveau des barêes aux modalités
des successions ou au plafond de
l'indemnisation mais ceci n'est pas
suffisant je crois que le moment est
venu également de présenter au
Parlement une nouvelle loi et qui soit
définitive fondée sur l'application
strict du droit commun et cela je
m'engage à le faire parce qu'il s'agit
de la justice et parce qu'il s'agit de
la
réconciliation et que la France ne peut
pas se permettre de maintenir plus
longtemps
des amertumes de cette nature et c'est
dans le même esprit celui de la
réconciliation que je crois que doit
être maintenant voté par le
Parlement le groupe parlementaire auquel
j'appartiens d'ailleur a fait à cet
égard une
proposition une loi d'amnistie totale et
sans
réserve
enfin il y a les Français de confession
islamique dont chacun sait qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui étrangers là où ils sont nés
et que trop souvent ils ne se sentent
pas des Français à partentière et pour
lesquels un effort important en
respectant leur identité culturelle et
religieuse bien sûr doit être fait pour
leur meilleure intégration à eux qui ont
choisi la France et qui à cet égard sont
plus français que beaucoup d'entre nous
en quelques mots mais j'aurai l'occasion
de le développer ce que je peux vous
dire sur ce
problèmes soit sur que ce soit sur les
considérations de politique économique
ou sur la place de la France dans le
monde il n'y a pas une grande différence
entre vos propos et ce de Monsieur
Michel Debray est-ce que ça n'est pas un
peu génant ce même programme défendu par
deux candidats issus du même
parti je vous ai indiqué tout à l'heure
les raisons pour lesquelles j'étais
candidat monsieur Debray a exposé les
siennes elles sont parfaitement
respectables la caractéristique de
l'élection
présidentielle et précisément de
permettre à toute personnalité ayant un
des propositions à faire de pouvoir le
faire et bien je n'ai aucun commentaire
à faire sur la candidature de Michel
debr avez-vous l'intention d'inuer
marche pasz monsieur avez-vous
l'intention d'instituer un impôt sur le
revenu monsieur ici à droite à votre
droite
voilà ah pardon monsieur Chirac
avez-vous l'intention d'instaurer un
impôt sur les grosses fortunes votre
groupe à l'Assemblée ayant sétant
déclaré favorable à un tel
impôt dans l'état actuel des choses
non et pour des raisons qui n'ont rien
de doctrinal simplement parce que je
crois que dans un premier temps l'effort
que nous devons faire consiste à
diminuer le le prélèvement de l'État sur
la richesse nationale alors nous verrons
ensuite ce qu'il y a le de faire dans le
cadre d'une réforme plus profonde de la
fiscalité pour le moment non s'il vous
plaîtsieur attendez alors cette fois-ci
je donne la parole je vous donne la
parole oui parce qu'il l'a demandé
depuis un bon moment cher char monsieur
le Président est-ce que vous considérez
que la pratique actuelle du pouvoir
fausse l'esprit des institutions de 1958
révisé en 1952 je veux dire le rôle du
Parlement dans l'état et celui du
Premier ministre
accessoirement je voudrais dire tout
d'abord
que je considère que nos
institutions ont fait leur
[Applaudissements]
preuve que nos institutions ont fait
leur
preuve et que pour ma
part je souhaite les défendre et en
aucun cas les
modifier même si sur tel ou tel point je
considère qu'aujourd'hui elles peuvent
être
amélioré je pense en particulier à la
pratique tombé hélas en dessuétude du
référendum et qu'il faut restaurer et
peut-être à ce titre d'ailleurs modifier
l'article 11 de la Constitution
ou la durée
du
présidentiel sur laquelle on peut
s'interroger mais je suis un défenseur
résolu de nos
institutions alors vous dites la
pratique
j'entends qu'ici ou
là on conteste la vocation du président
de la
République de conduire les affaires du
pays et bien je ne m'associe pas à cette
fausse
querelle le président de la République
reçoit du
peuple la légitimité et le pouvoir de
conduire les affaires il doit l'exercer
et l'exercer
pleinement
naturellement cela ne veut pas
dire qu'il doivent aller dans le détail
de l'exécution oubliant qu'il existe un
gouvernement faisant en sorte que ce
gouvernement perd un peu de son
existence
politique de même c'est vrai que le
Parlement avec la contrepartie qui
s'impose dans ce type de situation et
qui est l'émergence de la
technocratie mais ceci est une question
d'homme et non pas une question
d'institution s'il vous plaît oui oui
oui là en
face écoutez ah oui je voudrais revenir
par le biais de deux petites questions à
vos relations avec Michel Debray vous
allez réunir demain l'ensemble de votre
troupe
parlementaire et j'aimerais savoir si
les 28 députés qui ont soutenu Michel
Debray seront invités et ensuite
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous répondez à
la révélation faite par Maurice Druon
dans une interview au dernière nouvelle
d'Alsace sur la confidence que vous lui
auriez faite euh à savoir donc que vous
n'accorderiez plus votre soutien aux
députés qui soutiennent Debray et que
vous et que même vous opposeriez des
candidats à ces parlementaires au cours
des prochaines législatives ils s'attend
d'ailleurs à être démenti par
vous c'est Monsieur
Druon
euh je ne réunis pas Madame mes troupes
demain j'invite simplement à titre
personnel et privé mes amis à
déjeuner et je les invite
tous il y a bien des pièces dans la
maison du père je n'exclus
personne et d'autre
part je ne polémique pas avec Monsieur
Druon
monsieur
monsieur vous avez l'intention de vous
rendre à l'étranger avant les élections
présidentielles voilà une excellente
transition pour passer aux questions
relatives à l'étranger car je m'aperçois
tout d'un coup que nous avons été très
long sur l'intérieur il faudra se
limiter à une ou deux questions sur
l'étranger je j'ai l'intention
effectivement de voyager en France
c'est-à-dire en métropole et dans les
départements et territoires d'outremer
je n'ai pas prévu de voyage à
l'étranger sur les nous passons
maintenant si vous le voulez bien aux
questions de politique étrangère
monsieurz parlun risque de guerre
mondiale vous savez que le général de
Gaulle a laissé dans la Constitution le
principe de la limitation de la
souveraineté nationale absolue pour
organiser la paix au cours de vos
discussions sur le armement est-ce que
vous ferez appel à ce principe afin
d'assurer un contrôle du désarmement qui
soit enfin
efficace monsieur je nai pas très bien
compris le sens de votre question mais
je peux vous dire que je suis toujours
extraordinairement
réservé lorsqu'il s'agit pour la France
d'être présente dans des conférences de
désarmement et pour tout dire j'y suis
tout à fait
hostile
car j'ai observé qu'il s'agissait là
d'un piège et que pour la France le
problème tant que les armements seront
ceux qu'ils
sont dans un certain nombre de puissan
et notamment en URSS et aux États-Unis
et bien notre problème à nous c'est de
renforcer nos capacités de dissuasion
nucléaire de renforcer nos capacités
d'intervention et non pas d'aller
discuter et d'accepter je ne sais quelle
contrainte qui pour pour limiter notre
effort dans ce
domaine autre question monsur Shirak oui
Mons Shirak vous avez parlé de
renforcement des forceces d'intervention
française alors que vous n'avez cessé de
critiquer la politique du gouvernement
actuel alors quels sont queles seraient
les terrains éventuel d'éventuelle
intervention et avez-vous ou non
cautionner les précédentes interventions
euh française en Afrique ça c'est la
première question la deème question vous
avez critiqué toujours les accords de
Camp David alors pour vous quelles
seront les grandes
lignes d'une solution du problème du
Proche Orient sur le premier
point nous sommes liés avec un certain
nombre de pays notamment africains par
des accords de défense nous devons être
en situation de respecter ce que nous
imposent ces accords et pour cela nos
forces d'intervention doivent avoir les
moyens
nécessaires elles sont suffisantes en
nombre elles n'ont hélas pas les moyens
techniques et notamment les moyens de
transport qui leur sont nécessaire et on
l'a bien vu lorsqu'il y a eu l'opération
que j'ai approuvé de colvisi où nous
avons été obligés d'emprunter à
l'étranger des moyens de
transport en ce qui concerne le proche
orient c'est vrai j'ai mis des réserves
c'est le moins qu'on puisse en dire sur
les accords de cand David
pourquoi d'abord parce
que je considère qu'il n'y a pas de
solution au problème du Proche Orient
qui ne passe d'abord par un par la
solution du problème
palestinien c'est-à-dire de
l'attribution d'une terre à ce
peuple ensuite parce que il était
évident que ces accords all diviser la
nation arabe et que je pense que tout ce
qui divise la nation arabe n'est pas bon
ni pour elle ni pour nous de même que
tout ce qui divise l'Europe est mauvais
pour
nous alors à partir de là naturellement
j'aurai l'occasion de développer plus
longuement les propositions qui sont les
miennes dans ce domaine où la France
pourrait jouer un rôle qu'il s'agisse de
l'affaire du Liban ou de celle plus
générale
pre oriéas
elle n'a pas joué depuis quelqu temps
monsieur dimanche dernier au Club de la
Presse monsieur Mesmer a déclaré qu'en
ce qui concerne la politique de défense
de la France il pas eu de onit pas
transigé sur l'essentiel cette politique
est-ce qu' y des domaines dans la
politique étrangère par exemple vous
estimez qu'on a atint à l'essentiel de
l'héritage Gauliste
pidolien oui dans le
comportement mais en matière detique
étrangère c'est essentiel précisément
c'est une question de
fermeté Hamad journal Al hawad monsieur
Shirak au début de la guerre
irano-irakienne vous avez dit qu'il faut
absolument ne pas permettre à l'Union
soviétique à participer à la décision de
l'avenir d'une région qui n'est pas dans
sa zone
d'influence alors pouvez-vous me dire
comment peut-on continuer à ignorer le
rôle et l'influence et le poids de
l'Union soviétique dans la région du
golf et son entourage je n'ignore ni le
rôle ni le poids de l'Union soviétique
notamment dans la région du golf je dis
simplement que nous devons être parmi
ceux qui par leur fermeté marquent à
l'Union soviétique les limites de ce
rôle si vous êtes élu si vous êtes élu
président de la République française en
quoi dans ces objectifs ces méthodes et
ces moyens politique africaine
sera-t-elle différente de celle suivie
depuis 7 ans par le président
jiscardestin la
France a historiquement une vocation à
l'égard de l'Afrique elle en a également
une à l'égard du
développement c'est-à-dire de tout ce
qui touche à la dignité de l'homme nous
ne pouvons pas
laisser se creuser comme il se creuse
actuellement le faossé entre les nations
riches et les nations pauvres c'est
inacceptable tant sur le plan humain que
d'ailleurs sur le plan politique car
c'est porteur de division et de risque
que l'on n pas besoin de beaucoup
d'imagination pour
comprendre il faut donc que la France à
nouveau fasse connaître son ambition
dans ce domaine et qui ne peut-être que
d'apporter une solution à ce problème je
veux dire au problème du développement
en
général il se trouve que nous nous nous
sommes dans une situation
exceptionnel où nous connaissons pour la
première fois dans l'histoire du monde
contemporain à la fois une demande très
importante et
insolvable mais que l'on peut chiffrer
d'après les grandes organisations
internationales à quelque chose comme
150 à 200 milliards Dell de
dollars que l'on trouve également une
capacité de production dans les pays
industriels
inemployé et qui s'appelle le chômage ou
les moyens techniques
sous-employés et dont l'OCDE disait
récemment qu'elle
représentait une capacité de l'ordre de
100 à 120 milliards de dollars par
an et que nous avons enfin une capacité
de financement exceptionnelle dans le
monde et qui est la richesse des pays
producteurs de pétrole qui pour 1980
encaisseront environ 300 à 310 milliards
ont encaissé environ 300 ou 310
milliards de dollars ont dépensé environ
180 milliards de dollars et laisse
disponible de l'ordre de 120 à 130
milliards de dollars si j'ai cité les
chiffres c'est simplement pour vous
montrer que nous sommes dans cette
situation exceptionnelle où il y a à la
fois un producteur un consommateur et un
banquier et qu'il n'y a pas besoin
d'être un grand expert de l'économie
pour savoir que dans une telle situation
on peut trouver avec un peu
d'imagination et de cœur une solution
qui soit à la fois conforme aux intérêts
du développement de ceux qui ont besoin
de se développer qui soit le moteur de
la relance de économie des pays
industriels et qui permettent aux pays
producteurs de pétrole d'avoir la
garantie de placer sans risque leurs
capitaux qui par ailleurs ne pèseraiit
pas comme ils le font actuellement par
le biais des pétrodollars sur l'ensemble
du système monétaire international c'est
dire que nous devons donner l'exemple
dans ce domaine et c'est dans cette
esprit que j'ai proposé et que je
proposerai plus en détail que la France
soit le champion d'une grande d'alliance
pour le développement alors bien sûr
cela s'applique en priorité à l'Afrique
à laquelle nous sommes liés par des
liens humains très
solides et pour laquelle nous devons
faire un effort particulier afin de
l'aider dans son
développement c'est cet effort que nous
n'avons pas fait suffisamment depuis
quelques années où nous voyons notre
effort budgétaire de coopération qui
font comme neige au soleil et bien ce
n'est pas sérieux et ce n'est pas
convenable voilà pourquoi je proposerai
au cours de cette campagne sur le plan
des relations entre la France et et
l'Afrique plus de compréhension et plus
de solidarité c'est l'intérêt de
l'Afrique c'est l'intérêt de la France
Monsieur une dernière question monsieur
dernière question s'il vous plaît quelle
est votre atude vis-àvis le conflit
iraco-iranien qu
j'ai eu plusieurs fois l'occasion de
dire que je considérais dans ce conflit
que les torts incombéent à
l'Iran dans la mesure
où pendant des mois et des mois on a
entendu les pseudo autorités iranienne
Mané l'injure et l'invective permanente
à l'égard de de leurs
voisins dans la mesure aussi où ils ont
cru devoir remettre en cause les accords
d'Alger ce qui naturellement ne pouvait
finalement que déboucher sur une crise
militaire c'est ce que nous voyons hélas
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas changé d'avis
monsieur euh Antoine Basbous du réveil
de Beyrouth monsieur Chirac au cas où
vous étiez élu président de la
République quelles orientations
nouvelles donneriez-vous à la politique
française à l'égard du Liban soumis à
une double
occupation je n rentrerai pas dans le
détail car j'ai eu plusieurs fois
l'occasion de m'exprimer sur ce point et
notamment récemment dans les colonnes
d'un de vos confrères libanais et je
n'ai pas changé depuis d'avis je dirais
que la France devrait avoir à l'égard du
Liban plus de présence plus de cœur plus
de chaleur monsieur Chirac vous avez
tout à l'heure parlé de la solution du
problème palestinien comme condition
première au règlement des problèmes du
Moyen-Orient est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
reconnaître l'OLP pleinement et
entièrement comme le chancelier kriski
avec toutes ses revendications et ses
plans euh venant de la part de l'OLP je
crois que ce n'est pas que vous posez
très mal le problème je ne pense pas
que ce soit un problème de
reconnaissance de
l'OLP il faut d'abord conduire une
action qui en liaison avec tous les
partenaires et notamment l'OLP bien
entendu permettent de déterminer dans
quelles conditions on peut régler le
problème des
Palestiniens sans que pour autant soit
mise en cause l'existence et la pérenité
d'Israël et à partir de là et c'est ce
que n'a pas fait l'accord de cand David
une solution est peut-être tout en étant
difficile possible dans cette région du
monde monsieur la dernière question
monsieur puugot ce sera la dernière
question parce qu'il est maintenant 4h25
et nombreux sont ceux qui veulent
rejoindre leur rédaction monsieur puot
les Nouvelles Hybrides ont accédé à
l'indépendance l'été dernier cette
indépendance est traduite par la
persécution des Français et des
francophones et tout dernièrement la
semaine dernière l'ambassadeur de France
a été expulsé tandis que le gouvernement
du Vanou mène campagne contre la
présence de la France en
Nouvelle-Calédonie que pensez-vous
monsieur Chirac de la politique du
gouvernement français à l'égard de cette
indépendance des nouvelles
ébrilles je parlais tout à l'heure de
démarchees hésitant d'insuffisance de
fermeté et d'absence de dessin
je ne pensais pas seulement à
l'Afghanistan ou au Tchad je pensais
c'est loin et c'est petit mais c'était
la France aux nouvelles hbrides je
regrette profondément ce qui s'y est
passé et je crois que ce n'est pas à
notre honneur mesdames et messieurs je
vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie
[Musique]
je sais pas ça dev
pas
[Musique]